Gráfica la siguiente ecuación "y" es igual a -5x al cuadrado más 50x -120.
Vámonos a un lugar donde pueda escribir.
Bien tenía allá la ecuación "y" es igual a -5x al cuadrado más 50x -120,
y esta ecuación me determina una parábola. Como el coeficiente
de la "x" al cuadrado es negativo yo sé que es una parábola que abre hacia abajo.
En otras palabras mi parábola se ve algo así.
Allí está mi eje "x"
y por acá esta mi eje "y"
y yo sé que mi parábola hace algo como esto.
No es la parábola más bonita que he trazado pero servirá.
¿Ok? El modo en el que voy a encontrar la gráfica es buscando
las raíces de esta ecuación, las intersecciones con el eje "x", los puntos donde "y" vale 0 y
buscando el vértice que es precisamente el punto cuya coordenada "x" está justo a la mitad
de las intersecciones de la parábola con el eje "x".
Entonces antes que nada, lo que voy a observar es que si igualó esta ecuación a 0, para encontrar las raíces o las
intersecciones con el eje "x",
entonces esto se convierte en 0 es igual a -5x al cuadrado más 50x -120.
Ahora bien esta ecuación cuadrática la podría resolver por ejemplo mediante la fórmula cuadrática,
pero en vez de eso voy a tratar de factorizar este polinomio. Para facilitarme la vida voy a dividir todo entre -5.
Voy a dividir aquí entre -5 y aquí entre -5 y aquí entre -5, aquí entre -5.
Entonces bien 0 entre -5 es igual a 0, -5 entre -5 es 1, por lo que me queda "x" al cuadrado,
50 entre -5 es- 10
-10x y -120 entre -5 es 24 positivo.
Así que resolver esta ecuación, la que en naranja equivale a resolver esta que está en morado.
Bien entonces lo que quiero buscar, o lo que quiero encontrar son 2 números cuyo producto sea 24
positivo y cuya suma sea -10.
Estos 2 números son, los pueden encontrar por inspección, -6 y -4,
-6 por -4 me da 24 positivo y -6 -4
-6 más -4 me da -10 así que este polinomio se factoríza como
"x" -4 por "x" -6.
Estos son los factores de este polinomio y esto cuando se hace 0, para que este número valga 0 o
este cacho o este cacho tienen que valer 0, por lo tanto "x" vale 4 o "x" vale 6.
Esas son las 2 raíces que tiene mi polinomio, de modo que estos puntos tienen coordenadas, agarro otro color.
Este punto aquí sería el punto  4, 0 y este punto acá es el punto 6,0
y como les decía, el vértice tiene coordenadas que son precisamente la mitad de las coordenadas "x"
de estas 2 raíces, así que este punto tiene coordenada "x".
El punto que está entre 4 y 6 sería el punto 5 y para el valor de 5 ¿Qué valor toma esta expresión?
Pues si yo sustituyó aquí
por 5, podría escribirlo así "y" de 5
¿Cuánto vale esta función? Si sustituyo "x" igual a 5, pues vale -5 por 5 al cuadrado
más 50 por 5 -120,
¿Y eso cuánto es? 5 al cuadrado es 25 por -5 es -125,
más 50 por 5 es 250
-120 de modo que tengo
120 perdón, - 125 -120 sería -245
más 250 sería 5, entonces este punto es el 5,5.
Vamos a checar nuestro trabajo, bien mi primera intersección con el eje "x" se daba en "x" igual a 6,
mi segunda intersección con el eje "x" se daba en
4,0.
y el vértice de la parábola estaba precisamente en el punto 5,5
así que chequemos, y estamos en lo correcto.